grazie grazie e benvenuti e ringrazio
anche per la resistenza a chi è un po
sposo il no powerpoint giusto per
curiosità vi segnalo questo anti
powerpoint parti e nord europeo e fa
riferimento esattamente a questo se vi
iscrivete condividete un po la missione
che quella diciamo di non trasferire
solo immagine significato ma
sostanzialmente parole significato a
rischio ad un'applicazione come facciamo
è un po questo declinare quelli che sono
i nostri principi i nostri sogni in
azioni concrete perché evidentemente il
movimento di piazza e quella scintilla
che ci permette di esplicitare un
bisogno una sofferenza fa sapere al
mondo che c'è qualcosa che non va
dal giorno dopo però cosa succede il
primo acquazzone porta fuori
diciamo dal dall oggetto di attenzione
che cosa i vari movimenti occupai chi
probabilmente sta protestando anche
giustamente dai propri diritti
quindi cosa si fa probabilmente una
delle iniziative eco di trasformare
questo principio in azione e quindi in
impresa che abbia una sostenibilità nel
tempo siano esse profit non profit siano
esse spin off pubbliche e private questo
poco importa quello che importa è
generare un impatto positivo sui nostri
territori ed è questo che cerchiamo di
fare con la nostra vita
questo è un po la grande sfida che è
molto spesso ci troviamo ad affrontare
con miriadi di persone le iniziative che
cerchiamo di accelerare all'interno del
nostro network e quello appunto di dida
allo stesso tempo però all'interno di
questo nucleo non ho fatto un pò delle
cosiddette 5 emozioni fondati ne ho
paura gioia dolore quello che diciamo
risale in me è molto spesso prima si
parlava di violenza delle idee bene in
verità in rabbia e della rabbia che
coincide un po con quella assenza oggi
il definire fisiologica di attori capaci
di premiare talenti capacità visioni che
sono le banche gli intermediari
finanziari le fondazioni di origine
bancaria tutti attori che in verità
nascono come motore propulsivo di idee e
di contenuti di speranza è che oggi in
verità saranno legando sogni futuro
opportunità è solo colpa loro
molto probabilmente no per oggi insomma
cerco di avere questo tipo di focus
forse perché probabilmente ho cercato di
cambiare nel mio piccolo alcuni
equilibri
l'anno scorso con il passato governo ho
partecipato a questo di intenso di
innovazione che aveva anche sulla
declinazione social innovation la
ambizione di costruire un articolato
normativo su adesso utilizzare un po un
bel sunglo filo per un invito a
investigare anche sui motori di ricerca
questo tipo di di codici di strumenti e
quindi di proporre soluzioni di
strumentazione finanziaria innovativa
sui cosiddetti social impact bon su
crowd funding su social lending sul
microcredito bene di tutto un articolato
di otto pagine che tra l'altro è stato
anche un po pubblicato erroneamente
online e l'elefante diciamo ha partorito
un topolino sono due tre righe
sull'articolato su crowd funding del
decreto crash italia e che in verità
soffre un po di evidenti pressioni
istituzionali perché perché la frase che
mi sono sempre ma davvero sempre sentito
dire vabbè ma siamo in italia non
possiamo rischiare è in verità è proprio
all'italia che richiamiamo un po uno
sforzo di coraggio è un atto di coraggio
probabilmente non è tempo questo che
avvenga diciamo dagli apparati centrali
da questi mastodonti da questi mollo che
abbiamo di fronte a noi e quindi siamo
noi probabilmente vediamo le risposte
che stiamo incrementando un po in
termini massa critica la nostra
numerosità ma soprattutto i nostri
contenuti possono probabilmente generare
quel tipo di cambiamento ma non basta
non basta nel senso che come dire il
nostro investimento in rabbia che può
sopperire diciamo a questo nucleo che
molto spesso viene fagocitato da che
sentimento dalla paura
che ci fa essere evidentemente un po
remissivi e quindi un po vittima di
continui compromessi di non poter dire
di no
quante volte vi capita di non poter dire
di no per non scontentare qualcuno
bene il nuovo loft spesso e costruttivo
il no ci permette di se motivato
evidentemente di costruire una relazione
paritetica al termine della quale
abbiamo imparato entrambi ed è questa
dialettica che è già molto spesso si usa
un termine che magari le nuove
generazioni mi sento già vecchietto
dicendo così non conoscono però molto
senso si dice a è un approccio troppo
democristiano prende rita quegli anni di
anni 50 60 erano dettati da quello che
stiamo il mio amico andrea dezi
definisce un po il mondo dei salotti e
dei tavolini i salotti
mi chiamo luoghi all'interno dei quali
in buona sostanza si discuteva di golpe
talvolta si discutevano di leggi ad
personam quindi attuale evidentemente si
iscriveva evidentemente di un impianto
politico e di lobby che potesse
perdurare nel tempo nei tavolini
soprattutto nelle grandi città questo
era diciamo i tavolini erano frequentati
da artisti poeti musicisti e anche
imprenditori visionari che hanno dettato
anche diciamo una nuova forma di etica
imprenditoriale ma è questo scontro
semantico ideologico molto spesso anche
fisico dettava però comunque una
proposta no con la via di futuro una
capacità di costruzione è quindi
comunque un equilibrio
allo stesso tempo oggi in verità tutto
questo non avviene non avere perché
abbiamo un immobilismo enorme da parte
di tutti gli attori in gioco e questo
probabilmente secondo il mio
personalissimo focus è dettato anche
dalla mancanza di coraggio da parte
ripeto di banche e intermediari
finanziari in genere avviene perché
probabilmente non abbiamo forse la
capacità anche noi stessi cioè di
proporci in termini di massa critica e
di lobbying positiva
sono confronti il cal fanning è una cosa
sofisticatissima molto molto molto
interessante cioè possiamo contribuire
con un click al sogno di qualcuno e
probabilmente se dovesse poi la
frontiera anche della partecipazione
diffusa delle folle ad un sogno essere
anche remunerativa ed è questa la
frontiera che oggi ancora non riusciamo
a superare
altro tema è quello delle cosiddette
obbligazioni ad impatto sociale
l'hanno sperimentato in inghilterra new
york in questo momento ne sta lanciando
sono uno strumento molto molto molto
semplice è verità che prevede una
remunerazione a successo pieno
iniziativa ad impatto sul territorio
hanno incominciato con il reinserimento
lavorativo di soggetti svantaggiati in
inghilterra ma sono strumenti che
prevedono diciamo la connessione di tre
attori chiave l'ente locale chi poi il
progetto di reinserimento lavorativo di
riqualificazione urbana di probabilmente
dell'organizzazione anche l'unità ed ex
come questo possa beneficiare di
risparmi o investimenti da parte dei
cittadini che vedranno a successo
dell'iniziativa una remunerazione del
capitale investito
probabilmente in un orizzonte temporale
un po più lungo quindi abbiamo questa
nuova formula di capitalismo paziente
non stiamo pensando stiamo parlando di
filantropia stiamo parlando di
investimento positivo sin investimento e
un po più razionale un po più coerente
con i bisogni di tutti i giorni
ed è questo che probabilmente ci sta più
interno allontanando da quello che
diciamo
abbiamo sempre pensato fosse magari
l'unico modo di interpretare il nostro
cammino culturale sentimentale e
professionale e di vita a loro
esattamente chiedo di avere un po più di
coraggio lo stesso coraggio che
probabilmente molti imprenditori non
riescono ad avere proprio perché
blindati da questo tipo di risposta no
perché trovano davanti a loro un muro e
quindi ecco i suicidi ecco le morti
ecco la incapacità di reagire a questo
commento di di stand by e quindi allo
stesso tempo
la carenza da parte di tutto quel mondo
ha anche di start upper che abbiamo
visto prima di intrattenere anche con il
mondo della finanza
un rapporto diciamo di convenienza
biunivoca quali sono le opportunità
diciamo che possiamo vedere comunque
alla fine del tunnel la partita sono
esattamente come fece credere un po
nell'utilizzare gli strumenti che
abbiamo oggi a disposizione per i
sognatori per innovatori sociali sono
appunto le persone che credono in un
futuro migliore e che possono diciamo
interloquire con il soggetto bancario
per l'accesso al credito non all'interno
dei moli di questi castelli arroccati ma
probabilmente in spazi fisici
all'interno dei quali poter colloquiare
anche informalmente con questi attori
del cambiamento siano essi stessi change
maker i banchieri qui direttori di banca
perché quindi non diciamo delocalizzare
questo impianto relazionale in spazi di
collaborazione come coworking come i fab
lab all'interno dei quali dei semplici
sono in makers che potrebbero ideare
anche un business model con dei
prototipi che stanno ideando in questa
fase diciamo di generazione creativa in
tutto questo vedo evidentemente come
dire una scintilla di coraggio che ho
visto probabilmente in poche persone
durante il mio piccolo cammino
professionale e l'ho visto evidentemente
né nei miei soci quando l'undici
novembre 2011
abbiamo fondato una società e abbiamo
fondata non essendo assolutamente certi
se dovessimo pagare il notaio in euro
indire o in sesterzi tv ricordate c'era
chi scendeva in chi era sceso in campo
chi poteva salire in campo e avevamo una
situazione assolutamente instabile
mileto un po come quello attuale però ci
hanno creduto perché si va un po a
caccia del testimonial del sogno della
della prospettiva e noi abbiamo
continuato a crederci hanno contenuto a
crederci chi ci segue lo stesso tempo
sono gli hub sono le persone che credono
che questo sistema rete di accelerazioni
di social innovation possa generare
impatto positivo sul territorio è
scalare a livello globale ci ha creduto
evidentemente vuol dire anche mio padre
per finanziarsi finanziare la prima
azienda verità che oggi ha 40 dipende
senti ma che per dobbiamo sopportare il
peso di una trasferta ha chiesto 100mila
lire al salumiere di sotto casa ea 350
milioni della mia nonna la probabilmente
fatto chiamate con 14 colli quando
trasportato richiamo dalla puglia in
uzbekistan per tre anni proprio per
seguire mio padre probabilmente l'ha
fatto mia nonna quando ha avuto il
coraggio di esplicitare un dubbio che
aveva per dire dubbio è abbastanza
utilizzare come dire un po un eufemismo
ovvero era il primo bacio con mio nonno
e lì era convintissima di essere rimasta
incinta però avuto il coraggio dopo una
notte in zona di esporlo alla sua
migliore amica ed è questo probabilmente
anche il coraggio nel riconoscere i
propri limiti che cominciavano ad avere
e quindi promette arrivato anche il
tempo di liberarci di tutto questo
quindi un grazie davvero a tutti i
coraggiosi anima non può questa rete
formale ed informale ed eccita forza ci
dà la possibilità di restare in questo
territorio dalle mille opportunità
potenziali ma credevano evidentemente un
po essere palesate è sicuramente la cosa
che non riesco a perdonare che mi nuti
vira sempre più rabbia è sicuramente il
confrontarmi con persone che
evidentemente si posso sopportare cosa
la paura della morte non la paura della
morte fisiologica questa è una cosa
possibile e legittima la cosa che non
sopporto è chi ha paura della vita per
sé